[Music]
for centuries Our Kind has stayed hidden
on Earth
the darkness has found us again
prime
this is about the fate of all living
things Unicron
is coming
[Music]
come on
Becca Oh I thought we were boys
what a human here I'm nobody I ain't
even seen nothing I'm not even seeing
anything right now
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
in the end
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
foreign
[Music]
yeah baby
foreign
[Music]